je me prépare à aller travailler je
travaille comme soudas dans une shop des
structures d'acier il ce matin là j'ai
aperçu de la sûreté du québec en traits
de sam ans et au pied de la fameuse
jusqu'au alors je me suis approché un
petit peu plus pour voir qu'est ce qui
se passait j'avais entendu qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui se manigance et ce
matin et le quand j'ai vu l'escouade
tactique arrivés avec leurs fameuses 24
b commencent à monter la cote
mais ceux qui y vont tuer tout le monde
me demandait si elle a même des
journalistes pourra enregistrer la
catastrophe qui était avec ce produit
alors j'ai aidé quelques journalistes à
monter une côte dans la pinède
on est pris à travers la pinède à
travers le terrain golf et on s'est
rendue de l'autre côté de long s'est
rendu où était la barricade ou ce que la
sûreté du québec à l'entrée et en
arrivant en arrive à près de la
barricade
la fusillade a commencé on en est à la
phase dans le sol il y avait des bals
qui éclatent à narnia débat qui
éclataient en avant il y avait encore
dit la boucane lacrymogène alors lot est
ouverte avec les yeux qui brûlent est le
cas tout était fait ça a plu prévoit 30
secondes une minute
20 selon souhait c'est ça c'est passé
vite mais souhaite à ce jeu me suis levé
les journalistes sont comme était dans
chacun leur direction j'ai commencé à
suivre le fameux bulldozers qui écrasait
les shows de police sait s'en servir
la barricade j'ai commencé à suivre
sauva la côte puis je voyais des membres
de ma communauté courir sur les sur mes
côtés je les voyais passer
c'était comme un coup c'était comme un
rêve un rêve un peu comme un
accouchement
puis je me demandais que ce qu'on a fait
c'est quoi qui va les conséquences vont
être quoi